so uh how did you actually come up with
this idea because it is definitely not
like anything else on tv right now
that's really great to hear because that
was actually the intention too um well
actually it wasn't the entire i didn't
go you know what i want to make
something that's not like anything else
it actually started from a very truthful
uh place and it's there's a lot of my
own life experience wrapped up in
in all of the characters in this show um
you know i'm a single parent i've had to
navigate certain things that the
characters in the show have to navigate
um
the
i was just kind of very fortunate to be
at one particular situation
in 2019
where
there was a coincidence which led to the
genre element of this show revealing
itself
and once the genre element sort of
revealed itself
i suddenly had an avenue to explore all
these themes and emotions and
uh
and it made it a fun way of actually
being able to explore that and deliver
that to the audience so um
so yeah i i i
like i said i didn't go what can i do
that we haven't seen before the idea
just revealed itself to me and i just
kept following the sort of the the
truthful uh emotion behind that idea and
the genre element i think is the thing
that kind of made it
just pushed it up into that extra level
um which all of a sudden made it really
fun to make as well too
the series is six episodes um and uh
i've seen all six and my question for
you is how did you decide on that number
uh was it ever did you ever envision it
as less or more than that
uh
yes i look i spent i mean i spent a good
sort of six months outlining the series
and and no six
six felt like it was the natural number
for to to tell the story in the way that
i have
um
there was at one point there was um
there was some
outside
pressure
um of maybe adding another couple of
episodes to it and i would say that's
this actually was before we'd sold sold
the show as well too before we found our
home at peacock peacock thankfully we're
like on board from the beginning of like
no this is the right amount of episodes
for this story you know there's a
obviously the episodes work in a certain
way the first two episodes you're kind
of getting up to speed the way the
audience is getting up to speed with
some of the characters in terms of how
they're getting up to speed with the
with the story and then after that it
just kind of rockets to the end
um i'm i'm very sick of seeing
shows
where
you know i i i seem to sort of say every
time i watch kind of things going this
is like two or three episodes longer
than it needs to be or you kind of get a
couple of episodes you know you get four
episodes and you go finally the show is
starting so i didn't want to be one of
those shows i wanted it to actually just
the story dictated how many episodes it
should be so that's how we ended up with
six
when you actually got to peacock and
they bought the show how much were they
asking you hey
i'm glad this is going to be six
episodes but we want to know you have
like a five year plan or we want to know
you have more to this yeah um
when we were pitching the show
um
there is for me there's an arc of the
story which gets told over subsequent
seasons that this series where this
series ends
um for me it's the perfect ending of
like you being able to kind of feel like
the characters are in a very different
place at the end of this series than
they are at the beginning and they
wouldn't have reached that point had
they not have kind of come together in
the quite extreme way that they do
but the same way that this series is
about how do you how do you navigate a
new relationship when you have baggage
how do you bring a single child uh how
do you believe is you're a single parent
how do you bring a child into a new
relationship as well
uh
there's other stages of
a relationship
uh
that
subsequent series can deal with
effectively obviously
i mean i can't you know we don't want to
give anything away but they're a very
different unit at the end of the show
than they are at the beginning
subsequent seasons would kind of go into
exploring what that would mean
the opening credits of this series are
interesting and they get more
interesting as the series goes on um can
you sort of talk about designing those
yeah so that's a company called antibody
um uh
and a a director called patrick clare
who who did
uh true romance
sorry true detective at the crown
westworld on sort of top of other things
he's australian and i'm based in
australia he's based here as well too
i just love his work and um
i gave him a pitch of what i wanted the
opening titles to be i mean you've said
it exactly you're gonna you should be
questioning what they are and then
in episode three when everything is
finally on the table you go oh okay
that's what that's what we've been
watching all this time it was trying to
take something that was quite grotesque
and make it beautiful by showing it in a
very kind of close-up way
also that queens of the stone age track
kind of really articulates that same
sort of feeling as well that you know
and we play different parts of the song
as the series progresses but what i love
about the open titles is in the last
episode
and this was patrick's idea
um
you it ends on something very different
the like the last title the last image
that we have on the show is something
very different to how we started it
which is also what happens to the
characters yeah i like when credits
change a little bit where you actually
have to pay attention
yeah completely and not just you know
again not letting the audience do that
skip intro thing it's like no your
[ __ ] credits are an opportunity to
actually take you into the world of the
show
um so it was fun trying to just like
yeah keep people interested and engaged
and discovering it as the characters did
uh some a spoiler question or two um so
how did you actually come up with
designing uh the wolf because you
eventually gets revealed and um i'm just
curious how you designed
so our team that did that is a company
called odd studio which are based here
in australia they're i mean i think that
you know they are world-class they won
the oscar for fury road
um
and they also did uh design the zombies
for me in my last movie little monsters
i went to them and
basically said look just as i did with
little monsters i was like just do i
want you them to design and do the
werewolf that they've always wanted to
do they've never done a weird they've
done a two-legged werewolf before but
they hadn't done a four-legged werewolf
and so they were really excited being
able to uh do that
the only the only things that i the only
conditions that i gave them is that it
had to be a feminine werewolf and
knowing that it was either in the show
too
um uh everyone like had a lot of fun
designing a red red
werewolf as well
um so they built in these some really
beautiful feminine qualities uh into the
design of the wolf and that was the
point too which is like when we do
finally see her
um it's actually about making her
beautiful as as as much as she's scary
she's actually beautiful as well too so
um look i'm i'm i like to think i'm
smart enough that when you employ people
like odd or when you work collaborate
with people like god
it's not up to me to kind of like sex
like a whole bunch of design i wanted to
look exactly like this you just let them
run free and what they delivered back to
us was far better than i could have ever
imagined
did you get any pressure from anyone to
introduce the wolf sooner than the last
episode of the season look i was always
really upfront from the beginning that
we had to withhold it for as long as
possible because um
i think
it's a lot better leaving it up to your
imagination but then even in the last
episode where we do show her
it was also to seek that sequence which
is quite a sort of prolonged sequence it
was also about
withholding her for as long as possible
in that sequence too to go that's why
that last sequence is you know it's like
a shark attack on land so you don't
actually see her you hear her you feel
her presence but you don't actually see
her
but also was about showing gary in
episode two
seeing
seeing his expression as he's
watching what he's he's watching and us
being able to hear it
um
yeah no no it was like it was always
from the get-go is like
i wanted the audience to actually
forget in a way too that they're
actually watching a werewolf show and so
that when the show when the wolf shows
up in the last episode i wanted them to
be oh [ __ ] we're going to have to see it
now and now i don't want to see it i
want to see it when i when i know that
this is what the show's about i want to
see it but i wanted you to forget and
then not want to say it when she finally
did show up
uh assuming that the show uh is a hit
and you get to make a season two um had
you have you already thought about do i
about how much the wolf might now be
incorporated more now that you've
revealed it or is it one you know what i
mean
oh yeah yeah totally um
yes i mean i don't want to say too much
i mean i am like
like thinking of working on on you know
ideas for subsequent seasons but
the
it's it's not going to be this
the idea is it won't be the same thing
where now that we have shown the wolf
we can actually i feel like
show her uh like a lot a lot sooner
um and that's also the fun now and kind
of just constantly
the big part of this first series is
about subverting the audience's
expectations about what they're going to
watch and i know subsequent seasons
that's also going to be the fun in
yeah not just doing the same thing over
over and over again
i gotta stop there i'm just gonna say
congrats i hope it's a huge hit thank
you for giving me your time oh thank you
so much i really appreciate it cool have
a great day